the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
in the studios I'm Ryan
sicklerionsickler.com Ryan sickler on
all your social media listen go watch
the special go to my YouTube subscribe
there check out the special comment on
it share it like it still almost 700 000
views even after being taken out of the
algorithm not taken down you just gotta
go search it and find it and make it a
lot harder that's that's what's going on
um and I just want to thank you guys for
supporting this show we're here at the
new studio we got a lot of new stuff
going on I'm very excited about it some
things to tell you about uh and if you
gotta have more and you got to have the
patreon go to the patreon it's five
bucks a month it's the Honeydew with you
all and I promise you it's a cup of
coffee you get hundreds of episodes and
you're never gonna hear anything like
you heard on that patreon all right you
get the Honeydew a day early you get it
ad free you get it at no additional cost
it's five bucks it's been five bucks
we've never raised it all right so go
check it out and if you sign up for a
year you get a month worth episodes for
free alright that's how that goes down
and if you're looking for a new podcast
to listen to go check out my old podcast
the crab Feast with Jay Larson I'm
telling you
Kirsten will tell you we're on the road
Non-Stop and people come up all the time
they're touching my pitch in the crowd
they're yelling [__] the crab Feast it's
still a very thriving Community the
episodes are great go check it out
subscribe to that all right now if you
want to come see me on tour and uh I'm
in your city when you're there then
let's do it all August 11th here in La
at Flappers come out and check out that
show gonna have some special guests on
that August 18th and 19th Tampa Florida
September 1st and 2nd Springfield
Missouri September 15th and 16th we're
going to be in Tulsa the 29th and 30th
of September is Phoenix the 27th and
28th of October is Salt Lake City and
December 8th and 9th is San Francisco
California all right those are the dates
go get all the tickets at
ryansickler.com now that's the biz you
know we do over here we highlight the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers and I am
very excited to have this guest on here
today ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Mike Feeney welcome thank you
wow you startled me the way you said
that gotta fire it up
you know what I mean yeah it's like that
moment after lunch on a set and
everybody's got that lull you gotta kick
him in the ass yeah but yeah just to
quit you just sit there and listen to
that intro it lulls you a little bit it
did I wanted to fire you up yeah you
have a very like silky like Maple syrupy
voice you know it's very it's like I
could just kind of sink into a bath of
it you know all right well let's get
into a bath of that bro
um will you please before we begin plug
promote everything sure Mike
feeneycomedy.com for tour dates I'm
gonna be at the uh Algonquin theater in
Manasquan New Jersey doing a uh a
stand-up and live podcast with my
podcast here's a scenario with my Canon
and Brennan zagalo we each do stand up
then we do a live POD at the end very
fun
um I'm also headlining the den theater
on October 7th in in Chicago so if
you're around please come to that I have
a YouTube special out called Rage
Against the routine
um Mike youtube.com Mike Feeney comedy
and I just recorded and I directed and
I'm editing my own it's my second comedy
special that should be coming out in the
next uh month or two so we have to
haven't picked an exact date for that
yet but again youtube.com says mike
Feeney and at uh at I am Mike Feeney
across every social media all right you
got them all that's it I just I just I I
at one point I was going Mike Feeney
here I am Mike Feeney here and then I
just went blanket you know yeah no one's
taken I am Mike Feeney you know no there
is an at Feeney I really wanted to get
on Twitter for a while and then someone
I spent it was an inactive account I
spent years like and did like public you
know outcry things just as a bit to get
people to like report the inactive count
so they would delete it then they
finally deleted it I mean I must have I
must have posted hundreds of tweets
about this thing as a bit over the years
and they finally deleted it and then
within 24 hours uh somebody from like a
bank like a Prudential Bank got it and
then I was like listen I reached out it
was like some woman like you know like
listen Mrs Phoenix yeah
she's like Christian feeding come see me
at the bank for alone and I was like
listen I've I don't know if you know the
ground swell of of of work that I've
done to get this released and back so I
was like if you could just and then she
was like I personally don't care let me
let me send you to the corporate thing
and then I reached out to them and
they're like yeah we're just not gonna
We're not gonna let that go so uh after
all that after all that even though she
was willing to she was willing to but
she she's almost like a 50 year old
woman that just she didn't know what
Twitter what you know what I mean but
regardless so at I am Mike Feeney let's
keep it simple
um so let me let me learn a little bit
about you yeah we hung out before at the
store not long so where are you from
tell us a little bit about your
background first from Long Island New
York
um lived in New York City ever since
since I graduated college so
2008 and that's what I started doing
comedy and I've been doing it ever since
live in Queens got a wife and an
eight-month-old kid oh congrats thank
you all right yeah so that's uh that's
been a life yeah yeah it is
um but it's great but yeah so it's but
yeah growing up on Long Island it's like
a very you know suburbs but there's the
beaches and there's access to New York
City so it feels like a very uh we
always you always joke the thing in Long
Island people always go oh I can go to
Manhattan anytime I want because it's
you know an hour on the train no no one
ever goes you know what I mean they just
talk about going and then since then
Long Island has gotten more and more
like you know its own world you know
what I mean like the their politics have
very much changed people are like
hardcore you know identity politics with
everything that was crazy but they're
like hardcore like all my friends you
know we used to listen to like hardcore
music and punk music and we go to
concerts now everyone drives a Ford
F-150 and has two into back go and
listens to country music it's like you
guys live in the suburb in Long Island
in Long Island
yeah in parts of Long Island it gets
very like they're big country music
people now they think that they like can
identify with like cattle ranch culture
and stuff like that yeah yeah you know
what like Bruce Springsteen kind of has
this thing of being like I'm uh I'm just
like a working class like you know I'm a
blue collar I I till the Earth with my
hands remember that commercially come
out for like I think it was for like
Wrangler or or like some or Ford maybe
it was during the Super Bowl a couple
years ago where he's like installing
like fences on a ranch with his hands
and you're like dude you have been one
of the most famous people on the planet
for 95 of your life like you were a blue
collar guy for like 16 years yeah yeah
yeah
you've been this Elite rich but now he's
just like I'm just one of you you know
no you're not you even one of us that
you had your [__] driver's
license spring Steve okay and that's why
I don't know why I think it's Jersey in
New York but there's this Billy Joel
versus Bruce Springsteen thing they're
not even like really comparable in terms
of their music but it's a very
contentious like you either have to love
one or the other and they should tour
together then they really I mean they
would sell out Arenas but I mean but
Billy Joel to me again I have a Long
Island bias here but he is just like
talk about like a salt of the earth you
know what I mean there's no no bobbin
Circumstance the dude he just drinks he
drives his car into a tree walks home
like he's there's no ego there you know
he's just I'm a guy now he just takes
his helicopter from from his uh from his
house right to Madison Square Garden
does his you know nine million sold out
show and then takes it right back home
still possible yeah oh just hasn't put
out anything since the 90s it's crazy I
have a joke in my first special about
her saying like my wife and I's sex life
at this point being together so long
it's like going to a Billy Joel concert
because we're just playing the hits
known associate everybody's happy you
know
that's it you know
yeah but you're never gonna go to a
Billy Joel concert he's gonna be like
he's doing it earlier he did it last
night that's the only difference
so early
I mean you gotta love Billy Joel too in
our line of work what's the line close
the shop uh sold the house bought a
ticket to the West Coast now he gives
him a stand-up routine in La come on
yeah I mean Billy Joel
and he also like he pops into local like
Long Island music venues and just will
either like be there or sometimes he'll
like sit and like there's sometimes a
Billy Joel cover band will play in Long
Island and he'll just go hang out and
then he'll like jump on stage with them
for a couple songs so like people
they're seeing the ten dollar show just
happened to see Billy Joel in a 200 seat
it's crazy yeah he's just he's a good
dude I don't know I have no idea if he's
a good dude I want him to be a good dude
I hear you yeah yeah I hear you
um so tell me about growing up you have
siblings tell me about your parents only
child uh product of divorce parents got
divorced what age
writing like Thee I Hate Everything
phase of life you know like probably 12
13 adoles just like when it's hitting
you naturally even if your parents love
each other dude just Rage Against the
Machine and System of a Down and just
being like angry about everything and
why did your parents split uh I assume
the constant uh uh awful fighting that
that happened it was different like
anything like physical but just like
screaming I think they were a little bit
like you know my Dad my mom is a very
like she's a firecracker you know what I
mean she's just kind of I think even
after she had the kid she's like I still
want to go out I still want to like
party and be the life of this thing they
have kids young
um I don't know they were like they were
like about I think my mom was 28 and my
dad was like 31 or something like it
wasn't you know it was for sure
teenagers yeah no no no but they were my
mom was just kind of like I like going
out and my dad became a lot more of like
you know he was my dad that comes from
an Irish Catholic Family of you know of
of a bunch of siblings where it's like
you you work and you know he was working
80 hour weeks while trying to get a
graduate degree while also you know
raising a kid so he just was very much
like stay you know let's stay home let's
raise the kid and my mom was like you
know when I was in elementary school my
mom would take me out like to bars with
her really yeah when I was like yeah
dude I was like what year is that
um I mean I so I was born in 87 so I
guess this was like yeah that's later to
me I can't believe you could still do
that yeah that you could
but we did
there was there was this Irish bar that
we would go to a ton in Long Island uh
down in Port in Port Jeff and we would
uh you know it was literally a biker bar
like it was just an Irish biker bar that
place where it's like it's dark at 12
and there's people hanging out in the
bar and I this is how young I was
um you know those little like pop shot
basketball kind of they had one of those
I was young enough where they put me
inside the cage on the other side of
where the balls go down and I would just
be free throwing from two feet out while
there's like a playpen while your mom's
drinking too whoa that was your [__]
plate man
to this day do you have a Pack and Play
Joe I'm telling you I did that's your
package you got an eight month old
I'm telling you it's my Slumdog
Millionaire I never lose a pop shot to
this day dude it's like a muscle memory
I know the touchdown best babysitter
ever yeah
and like yeah dude it was just a biker
bar and I would uh you know there was
some like there was some rough crowds in
there and stuff but I remember uh
apparent my mom tells the story of one
time I went up to like apparently the
you know the most standoffish don't [__]
with this biker guy because he's always
in a bad mood just let him sit at the
corner of the bar and drink I yeah like
the leather you know vest on it all that
stuff and I went up to him and I I lick
it like a kid you know I'm a child and
it was like I was like oh sir I was like
you have some I didn't I couldn't even
say spaghetti I said you have some
spaghetti on your shirt and then he
looked down and I flipped his nose just
flicked his nose and it was like the
record scratched everyone everyone was
on the edge of their seat you know and
then he laughed about it I was like ah
all right
killed seven people yeah he's just
stomping them yeah
but all right so wait hold on why is Mom
hanging out in a biker bar is she that
type of she came from she spent she
spent college in Florida she used to
ride Harleys so she caught your mom yeah
dude you do not look like you come from
a Harley mom I know I know she's got two
bikes again she didn't know what's her
name is it like Sharon Debbie yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so she was she was
very much like yeah no tattoos either
which is crazy I thought she for sure
would have got someone a lot of denim
leather and stuff
[Music]
so so wait this is great dude so Debbie
comes from a Harley background like sort
of like was her dad or your grandfather
or uncles anything or is that just her
thing my uh my heart she had a uh she
has an older brother my uncle who's I
think like 12 years older and he had a
bike at one point but he's more just
like he's a musician but my grandfather
was like World War II vet like police
car police officer police officer he was
like uh NYPD for like 37 years like he
was but he was also weirdly enough like
the most loving like you know for a guy
who was in World War II for a guy who
did all that [__] he was the mo he's the
most like he always said I love you he's
very affectionate he was crazy it was
like the opposite you would give him
every excuse he was born in 1920. it's
like you give him every excuse to be
like you know a racist or like or like a
hardened not emotional guy and he was uh
to his credit he was he was the best
that's great yeah all right so Mom's
hanging out in biker bars not because
that's where she can get away with
taking her kid but she also is of that
those are her people she was that elk
yeah and was your dad also in that world
who just okay no they talk about that
they grew up a block they grew up two
blocks away from one another and my
dad's best friend uh introduced them and
weirdly enough my dad lived on Deb
Street which is a very nice yeah yeah
very strange um but like it turned out
to be a dead end Street yeah
they were they were I guess they would
party I guess and you know before they
had me or something but then I think it
was again just that different ideas of
like once we had the kid like let's be
you know a more you know traditional
household and you know and my and my dad
would try to be like let's take him to
church and everything but then like the
second I I was I was Catholic the second
week I would take him to the church or
Harley Davidson yeah my mom did not go
to church with us she would like she
would stay back and like make breakfast
so that when we came back and everything
but like just you and your dad would go
yeah I think my mom went the first few
times and then was like I'm not making
it uh but do you remember because kids
are smart do you remember
at early age like maybe it was wrong or
whether it was wrong or not like was
hang out with Mom more fun and hang out
with Dad for sure because yeah because
Dad was like more of a disciplinary and
like he wasn't he like he didn't even I
don't even think my dad believes in God
I think he just was kind of like this is
what you're supposed to do you know
especially coming from an Irish Catholic
Family you got to go to church and the
second I like got my confirmation we
literally never went ever again that was
like the last day we ever so did you get
that document yeah
yeah exactly so it was just graduated so
I think there was like constant fighting
about like you know like that kind of a
we would come home it would be probably
like I don't know it would be way past a
bedtime for a child on a school night
yeah yeah we'd like come back and my mom
would have to be like you know the
prepping in the car of like we don't
have to like say where we were you know
like that kind of a little bit she
always at the same spot essentially yeah
yeah yeah so which again it just became
kind of like a contentious thing and
then they would always fight about which
you know looking back on you like I
think my dad had pretty pretty good uh
claims you know for being angry and
stuff like that so it was like that was
for sure a uh a constant source of
fighting for them because then my mom
felt like she was being like she was
being like turned into just like a house
Mom kind of a thing and I don't know all
this other stuff but she also had jobs
too she also she worked in like nail
salon she had bought a nail and hair
salon like six months before she got
pregnant with me and then that was like
well I can't do this and then she just
worked in nail salons my whole life
which was great I always got free
haircuts you know and stuff like that
thanks man thanks dude I would just I
would like sweep up hair and like you
know I would also make terrible prank
phone calls using that thing when I got
older and stuff it was uh it's just
entertaining yourself while this is
going on yeah the only child thing man
you know it's like all my neighbors had
like five kids so I was always like that
kid who was you know I would hang out
with them then they would go back home
and continue playing and I would be like
ah [__] so I'd do my own you know it's
where you get an imagination I guess
yeah you're an only child but at one
time I was at my mom's uh hair salon
again I was young I don't remember how
old but definitely like 10 or under and
I like
I would there's a phone in the back like
old rotary phone and I just was like
here's a fun prank and I'll just call
9-1-1 and then I called 9-1-1 and then
they answered and I hung up and then I
was like that was kind of fun and then I
picked the phone and I called 9-1-1
again and then I hung up and I was like
that was a fun bit for just me and then
I just kept being going about my
business and then you know 20 minutes
later two police cars come up and
because they think like a hostage
situation is happening you know what I
mean there's like multiple calls with a
click
so they're like something terrible is
happening so they they said police and
the cops come in and they're like what's
going on and now the whole you know
there's like a busy hair salon there's
plenty and everyone's like who who
called 9-1-1 who called 9-1-1 and I'm
having that moment of like I'm gonna be
in so much trouble I'm gonna have to
admit it to me and then there was a
mother there with like her like kids
that were a little bit younger than me
and they were kind of being like a
terror and she was like it was probably
my kids I'm so sorry and like these kids
got in so much trouble
yeah I'm like I wouldn't be the kid
sweeping hair that kid the most innocent
of boys you know oh and I got away with
that but yeah it was so when your
parents split do they stay close in
proximity are you bouncing back and
forth are you primarily with Mom or Dad
I was with mom my my uh my great my
great uncle had just died and he lived
probably like a half hour away so my dad
moved there so I was doing that for a
couple years and then my dad eventually
moved to New York City so then I was
just taking the train into New York City
every week about how old how old you
start uh probably like
14 I guess maybe or something like that
and then up and through you know up
until yeah he lived there for 20 years
in in uh the east side of the long of
Manhattan so that was cool though it
felt cool to like take the trade into
the City and all that other stuff like
it was a very like exciting you know
exciting time to be like at Long Island
could be like I'm going into the city
every week you know and did your mom
remarry or they both got my dad's
remarried my mom got re-engaged
um everyone's always like when's the
wedding what what why don't you have a
date and she's like I'm never getting
married again and they go why and her
exact line is I already have the rock
where is he going we are like all right
where is he going oh yeah where would he
go you know where does he got to go let
him find something better
which works for me because then if if
she dies the money comes to me and not
to you know poor Jeff um but uh but it's
interesting yeah it is I I think about
it all the time
um it's just this I was so funny I had
an Uber Uber driver bring it up to be
marriage and it's just this archaic
contract like if anyone outside of
marriage if this was a business contract
go look man if this thing goes great
this is going to be amazing right but if
you [__] up or even if they [__] up
you could lose this and this and this
and this you would [__] say if it was
a business proposal most people I feel
like would go I don't know it's too much
risk that's too much way too much it's a
60 uh chance of failure yeah that's the
other thing you start throwing stats on
top of it yeah yeah I mean I would I was
never I was never the I the guy Goldie
and Kurt did it right man yeah they did
dude I'm not they did it right just just
be yeah just be like partners and uh you
know share a life just they have
everything that everyone else does
except for paperwork right even if they
are legally whatever now I know Common
Law whatever but still yeah there's no
State involvement there's certain things
though the government doesn't need to be
involved in your wedding yeah but
there's other things where you're like
access to health insurance and like you
know power of attorney if I'm a
vegetable you know what I mean there are
those things where you're like it'd be
nice to have somebody I was never gonna
I never saw myself getting married
especially coming from divorce I was
like I would never be like you know and
then I just you know you meet the right
person and whatever and I met her early
you know in college like in my freshman
year of college I ended up meeting and
we're still together now and it's great
but I think my grandparents are like my
grandfather was a police officer and my
grandmother married 67 years it's like
those are the that's like the people
that I look to to be like that's the 67
yeah their story is like I have to like
write a movie about it at some point
they just kind of like this The Notebook
sort of thing where they were this is
the same grandfather Yeah Yeah so he was
born in 1920 she was a little bit uh
younger than that and they met um and
they would hang out in the neighborhood
my wife my grandmother was like obsessed
with him he was like a little bit older
so and then um you know they would hang
out in Flushing and College Point Queens
and you know just so poor they were both
soap it was like depression they had
nothing you know and then my
grandfather's brother World War II
starts my grandfather's brother gets uh
drafted into the war my grandfather
didn't get drafted but he's like I'm
gonna go sign up so he wanted to go to
the uh the Navy I think he won so he
went into New York City took the police
test so that way he's like I did not get
drafted he hadn't got drafted yet I mean
maybe he said I'm gonna go where I want
to go I guess yeah yeah he was just like
I wanna I gotta do my duty my brother's
going I'm going so he went into New York
City to take the police test so he'd
have a job when he comes back and like
one of the physical tests was like the
hurdles and on like the first hurdle he
like clipped his foot and then like
landed directly on his knee and then had
to do the rest of the test so his knee
was like blowing up so he got done with
the test he's in Manhattan he gets out
he's like limping around
and he says to like a person walking the
street he's like where is the Navy
recruitment center and they were like oh
it's like 15 blocks it's right this way
and then you make a left and he was like
oh okay he's like where is the Army
Recruitment Center and they were like oh
it's like across the street and then he
went there
so he just signed up for the Army he's
like we're an army yeah
so he did like he did like 52 missions
across he was flying yeah he was like
this giant like you know those giant
bomber planes and stuff like that he did
and um and even when they came back you
know they were so he was so poor and
like they were so poor which now becomes
like a beautiful thing but they were so
poor that my grandmother's wedding dress
was made out of my grandfather's
Parachute from the war like his silk
parachute and then she actually still
fit in it for their 65th wedding
anniversary it was crazy yeah that is
nuts yeah and then he like and then he
wears that dress right now it's probably
at my mom's house down in Florida yeah
he's got that yeah Debbie's got out
there [__] tying it on her back and
going wheelies and [__]
watch this yeah look at Grandma's dress
in the wind yeah it was crazy dude but
um you know and then he worked like I
said 37 years NYPD two kids you know
like and they just were like they're the
cutest couple you've ever seen in your
life they just were always you know very
fun and laughing a lot together so they
were a good Beacon of like love can be a
thing you know
um so yeah I don't know liquid IV the
number one powered hydration brand in
America is now available in sugar-free
years in the making hydration multiplier
sugar-free uses a proprietary zero sugar
hydration solution with no artificial
sweeteners they've got tons of great
flavors and even some new ones like
white peach and Seaberry the travel
packs make it easy to use daily even
when I'm on the road one stick of liquid
IV and 16 ounces of water hydrates you
two times faster more efficiently than
water alone liquid IV combines science
back zero sugar technology with the
Brand's commitment to delicious real
flavor no artificial sweeteners and zero
sugar with a proprietary amino acid
allulose blend for a sweet taste without
the calories or raise blood glucose
levels you get from sugar contains eight
vitamins and nutrients for everyday
Wellness with three times the
electrolytes of leading sports drinks
plus it's non-GMO free from gluten dairy
and soy real people real flavor real
hydrating now sugar-free grab your
liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free and bulk nationwide at Costco
or get 20 off when you go to liquid
iv.com and use code honeydew at checkout
that's 20 off of anything you order when
you use promo code honeydew at liquid
iv.com the hair care products that you
use can make or break your hair health
over washing color treating heat styling
and product usage can clog the scalp's
pores or cause dryness leading to a poor
environment for hair growth while
neutrophils hair growth supplements
Target the root causes of thinning hair
from within neutral full scalp Care
Formulas help create a healthy
environment for improved hair quality
the shampoo scalp mask and scalp Essence
are each gentle yet effective and they
work to exfoliate purify and balance the
scalp for improved hair health
neutrophone supplements are the
foundation for healthy hair growth while
the scalp care products create an
environment for hair to thrive with just
a simple daily routine these formulas
set you up for the healthiest hair yet
take the first step toward improved hair
and scalp Health now for a limited time
neutrophones offering our us listeners
ten dollars off your first scalp care
order when you go to nutrifold.com scalp
and enter promo code honeydew find out
why over 4 000 Health Care Professionals
recommend neutrifold for healthier hair
n-u-t-r-a-fol.com scalp and enter promo
code honeydew for ten dollars off your
first scalp care order this is available
only to U.S customers for a limited time
that's nutrifold.com scalp promo code
honeydew for ten dollars off your first
scalp care order now let's get back to
the dude
um another thing we were talking about
before we recorded um you mentioned you
had some surgeries and stuff and I
wanted to talk to you about that because
you said you've had quite a bit yeah
yeah go back to the beginning and tell
us what happened what happened are you
like born with well first issues first
yeah I mean the first thing the thing
that I was born with um was I had like
uh it's called pectus excavatum which is
basically like a concave chest like my
my CH almost looked like like a dented
in ping pong I I knew a kid in um high
school that had yeah yeah it's so funny
because my best friend in elementary
school name yeah my best friend
[Laughter]
yeah 100 well it's so weird because my
best friend as a kid also had it so I
thought like it was way more con he
lived in my he lived a block from me so
I was like I thought like two and a
million
exactly so like you know obviously in
the same Clinic yeah so obviously like
as a kid like that was a pretty big
source of like uh you know
self-consciousness and being like you
know in public I was oh I like my family
would tell me it would be we'd be at the
pool or at the beach or something I'd
always kind of be like you know I think
I would be like pretending I was cold to
kind of like cover my chest and stuff
like that and then
um there was a surgery they used to be
they used to do back when I was a kid
where they would literally like cut you
from like your chat the top of your
chest all the way to your belly button
like almost like butterfly you open
break your ribs and like reconstruct it
was like this barbaric crazy thing so my
family thank God never got that for me
when I was young and then when I became
came like is it something they knew when
you were born or just over time when you
started growing they could see it was
growing differently they knew I had it
when I was born and then it was getting
like it was starting to get like worse
when I was because I would get headaches
like every day this is what I want to
ask you so is this a surgery that you
absolutely have will it will it end up
pushing in on lungs yeah they said it
could eventually like uh go like push
onto my heart like at some point in my
life so it was like you know so when I
was like 15 they came out with this
other like brand new revolutionary
surgery in Norfolk Virginia where
basically this guy like he created this
like stainless steel bar that he just
you do us a slot you do a slice on the
side of your rib and they basically put
this bar in and then they just kind of
turn it so it just pops the chest out
and then you keep the stainless steel
bar in your chest both sides yeah well I
mean they have it it's like yeah it's
just like a straight across and they
keep it they keep it in your chest for
three years you had this I had this so I
I got it when I was six team and I and I
went and got this surgery and then you
get this stainless steel bar and it just
it pops the chest out and then looked
normal for me yeah it feels it's good
now it's a good time you know like I
feel like I forget that I honestly
forget that that was ever like a whole
part of my life you know what I mean you
never just like dump milk down and just
let it just splash dude when I had a
when I had like a hole like a thing down
here dude I'd put like popcorn in there
when I was a kid it was like a little
bowl you know like Eminem yeah 100 man
it was for sure it's like a straw
so I got this surgery I got the surgery
at 16 I had to keep this bar in my chest
for three years till you stopped growing
so so you're like after 18. how does
that affect your life can you play
sports nope that's where it affects my
life is first off you have a bar in your
chest and you feel uh and it's like like
laying on my side felt it just feels
weird and [__] I mean like probably not
but it felt like it it feels like it was
yeah dude oh for sure like if you would
hit it it would like really waking up
from that surgery was like pretty in
terms of like pain level it was like one
of the worst like some guys though get
it so bad that they like they have to
get two bars because they're like taller
and stuff which is even brutal but I got
this one because I was getting headaches
every day of my life every day and they
said it was because I had the lack of
oxygen from being able to like get full
lung capacity from the chest so I get
this surgery and because of that they're
like you can't do football I mean this
is my was always my frame anyway but
like you can't do football you can't do
like hard contact like sports yeah
so I did like track and field and like
crew it was like rowing and stuff like
that so I did those things but like I
never really enjoyed that you know I
always wanted to do like baseball but
[__] braces for your ribs yeah inside
it's so straight you know and it's like
so that was obviously like a whole story
and then after my freshman year of
college in between freshman year and
sophomore year I had to go get the bar
removed which is what is that how's that
work uh
it's like you wouldn't even know did I
have like two little scars they just
literally like yeah they just snapped
they just pull isn't it isn't bone
around it though you think it came out
that easy are you awake
splinter out of the inside of your body
um no yeah so I had that done so that
was like that was obviously the most
serious of the surgeries that I had
because that was like a major you know
reconstructive surgery and then when I
was like
whatever year however I will do when it
was like 2001 or something I think
around that time I had a uh I had
appendicitis which was like a crazy
night because I was like my dad had my I
was with my dad that weekend he had
taken me this is when he was still
living on Long Island so it was before
he moved to the city but we went into
the city to go see a concert we actually
we went to BB Kings uh the venue uh and
we saw uh John Entwistle of the who uh
and this was actually his last concert
before he died and he was completely
deaf uh at that point is that right all
of the years of the you know and all the
play so he was completely deaf and it
was the loud to this day the loudest
concert ever because he has no idea how
loud it was the loudest concert I've
ever been to in my life and then we were
coming back it was just like this whole
crazy day where like I'm like I'm like
starting to be in pain we're driving
back to Long Island there's so much
traffic so then my dad like every like
it's literally bumper to bumper so my
dad's like I'm gonna go off the on-ramp
just to like get out of this and like a
bunch of cars we're doing it and then
like a hundred cars must have taken that
on that on-ramp off and then like the
police came and gave like my dad a
ticket and then gave like the next five
cars ticket so we got tickets so that
slowed us down even more so then my
dad's pissed we stopped at a gas station
and my dad like moved he like went to
reverse his car and he backed his car
into a like Ninja motorcycle and and
these people yeah
she's more the Harley but this is like
these people you know and he he knocked
the guy's bike over and then it got like
caught under his car so my dad went to
like move forward and was just dragging
this dude's bike and this guy who like
he dressed there did he see it yeah yeah
dude this guy was like a like a probably
20 something like just like black
RoboCop like the way he was dressed in
like the whole thing dude and he went up
to my dad's window and like just [__]
was bashing the back of my dad's car
where like all of the you know it's
Spider Web the whole back window we had
this old like Toyota Celica so it was
like almost that hatchback kind of thing
bash that and then him and my dad are
like like screaming at each other I
think my dad's gonna get killed I'm like
freaking I'm gonna cry I'm screaming I
don't know what's going on so then we
have to fill out the police report with
all that so it's like now it's like one
or two in the morning it's like the
longest night ever and I'm like again my
stomach is killing me this whole time we
like go over the bump to get out of the
to get out of the gas station and like
the second we hit like the whole back
windshield falls into the car
I
feel like pieces of glass my dad's
pissed you know just the worst day ever
and his son won't stop [__]
complaining about his stomach for some
reason yeah yeah and then I woke and
then like an hour later I was like I my
dad was just like this we gotta go to
the hospital and immediately they're
like you gotta get you know surgery and
stuff so then I had the appendicitis
which was fine you know it's whatever I
mean all compared to other surgeries
I've had it was fine and then uh sudden
said I've also had three different
shoulder surgeries why what's going on
well I had I tore a labrum uh and I was
I tore like I think playing basketball
or Ben Preston and I had it torn for
four years so it was just constantly I
couldn't lift my arm like over this for
years and I just figured that was just
my way of life got the labrum surgery
that fix it then like a year later the
labrum started praying again but then
they realized because I did an MRI is
this all a result of what happened in
your chest originally is this like no
but this part is actually kind of a
weird Oddity thing as well is that they
found out the reason I've been having
shoulder problems because inside the
ball of my shoulder like in the in like
solid bone where it's supposed to be
solid was completely Hollow there was
like a cyst inside the bone so my
shoulder's been like weak my whole life
which has caused all of the other
compensating and issues for it and stuff
like that so they had to they did two
surgeries at once where they went in
drilled into the bone took out the the
you know the cyst replaced it with donor
bone so it would make it a solid bone
and then while that surgeon was done the
other surgeon tagged in fixed up the
labrum shaved down the collarbone all
that other stuff and then did that and
that was like the last one I had was
during it was during covet it was like
2021 or something where it was like I
was alone in the hospital all that other
[__] how long were you in there I was
just there for the day but like what's
crazy is you weren't allowed to have
family or friends in there with you and
I was you know they make you not eat for
so long beforehand and I was I'm pretty
I don't love needles but I'm like okay
with them but this woman came over and
she was like uh the nurse and I go I
gave her my hand to put the IV in I'm
[__] I know this this game by now you
know and she was like I'm actually gonna
put the IV in your wrist and I was like
the rip wow he's that one that wants to
experienced yeah and I'm like look how
veiny my I'm like I'm right they're
right here it's no reason and she's like
I mean just like stabbing my writ just
not finding a vein it's just over and
over again and then she finally got it
in and I was like okay and then she's
like you know what it's not bend your
wrist yeah and she was like it's not
dripping up enough she's like I'm gonna
take it out I'm just gonna put it in
your hand I was like and for some reason
when she was taken out of my wrist dude
that I just was like apparently what I
said out loud was like nope don't like
that and then I just passed out
just fully swooned I was like everything
got black and then do it and then I wake
up and I think like I don't know what's
happening you know when you I don't know
if you've ever passed out do the
collapse the blacked out but okay yeah
well if you wake up you don't know how
long that could be 10 seconds or 10
hours I thought the surgery was over
that's how confused I was and the worst
part is I wake up from the the blacking
out it is like you know nurses around me
they got ice chips on my neck and I was
like oh whoa that was like a crazy
surgery and I looked down and they were
like we had to wait for you to wake back
up before putting the IV they didn't
even put I still had to go through the
whole process of putting the IV in again
after that where they're like now that
you're awake let's put it back in I was
like you guys are monsters absolute
monsters so
um but yeah the surgeries went well now
it's like I'm the strongest my
shoulder's the strongest it's ever been
in my life because apparently when
you're a kid you can get some CIS but
they're supposed to go away but mine of
course did not so yeah dude it's been
it's been a nightmare but you've also
had a lot of injuries that aren't just
from that to why would it what did you I
don't know Daredevil kid I wasn't yeah I
was a daredevil kid I touched it like I
basically had like jackass was like such
a giant influence in all my whole life
like that was right at the perfect this
is what's interesting to me about that
though is jackass is a group effort
you're a solo kid all of my boys we all
yeah it was a group we weren't just
around the house by yourself no no but
all right but I was I was always Smart
in that I was obsessed with cameras like
I always had like a camera ever since I
was a kid like I always would be the one
filming things and I was very good at
like talking my friends into doing
jackass stuff and they'd be like why
don't you [__] do it I'm like yeah
but I'm filming it dude it's gonna be
great so I always got to like all of the
ones that were like violent or like
things where it was like you know we're
gonna just you know roll out of a moving
car or like you know do this all this I
would just convince them that I'm gonna
get the best footage of this and
convince them to do it and it was really
uh it was really quite a lot but also we
did dumb [__] in my car it's just a we
did a lot of like Reckless all that
stuff when they would post that thing on
jackass in the beginning where they're
like warning don't try this at home we
won't look at some Mission tapes don't
even try this we we would see that and
we'd be like I know what they mean
they just want to see a good one that's
what I want I get it legally they gotta
say it but like they're interested you
know what were some of the wildest ones
you guys did
um I mean we would just drive a lot of
it was like car related stuff man which
wasn't you know which wasn't great but
like we would drive recklessly we would
also like get into fights with motorists
you know what I mean like start fights
you know I'm saying like we would go to
like McDonald's and get like food and
then we'd be out of like a red light
with a car and then like the second the
light would turn green we'd just like
throw the Tomato like onto there like
you know what I mean like did you throw
a milkshake just being like piece of
[__] kids and stuff like that and then
have and then like most times people
Long Island like they will chase you
they will chase you until you get away
and my buddy was like a getaway driver
he just he would know he would just
directly blow through red lights just
cutting across lanes and stuff like that
the worst one was we um we did a fake
kidnapping uh yeah so we drove we were
down in uh in Port Jeff outside of a bar
that had like a line outside of it and
we drove up
um we had our friend in the trunk and he
was banging on the on the roof and we
opened it we were like shut the [__] up
you know like pretended to hit him and
then got back in the car and people were
like what the [__] what was that you
know they're all horrified and then uh
this other car I guess like this
Samaritan like person that saw it
started like kind of like chasing us so
then my buddy goes into his evasive
maneuvers blowing red lights cutting
across double yellow lines just
illegally driving like crazy
and then like after like five minutes of
Jason as they [__] put a light on
because it was an undercut it was
undercover cops oh [__] uh so they pull
us over draw the guns guns are out guns
they saw a kidnapping yeah this guy is
illegally driving you're lucky they're
not shooting and they're asking later
yes yes yes yes uh so they so they they
pull the guns on us they go get the [__]
out of the car and they do that thing
and we're just trying to explain to them
but they're not listening you know we're
like we're like 17. we don't know
because this is also what every person
does when they get pulled over you're
telling them they're for no not even on
this thing no we're boys and they
literally do the thing where they go
what's in the trunk and we have to be
like
so like it's a guy but like we're boys
and he'll tell you we're boys when you
open it you'll see you'll see and we
open it and my buddy who's been getting
like thrown around you know what I mean
in the trunk they open it he's like
they're like are you okay and he's like
no no they're my friends and they don't
believe him they think he's scared so
like you know like because we're behind
him
[Laughter]
so he's like they we had to like show
ideas we had to show pictures of us like
from like being friend like he just we
had to call the the his parents so I had
to call his parents to be like is this
we gotta is this a real kidnapping is
this kid just lying and stuff like that
and then they I mean somehow almost
credits of the cops for doing that at
least they could have just been like
yeah and you guys really could have been
[__] that kid up yeah like the Dahmer
situation where they just let that
little boy back up into the thing um but
yeah we somehow impossibly as far as I
can remember got away like there was no
guns all our parents like were called
that was like the worst of it but they
didn't do it they didn't give my friend
any tickets for all the speeding that he
did and all that other [__] so yeah man
I mean just jackasses you're idiots it's
just terrible
anybody ever really get hurt
uh my friend had like yeah he got like
his knees [__] up and stuff like that
just from like you know literally
shopping carts you know going in those
metal great shopping carts pushing them
as hard as you can into a curb and just
seeing what happens that kind of a thing
we had this go ahead sorry also this is
just a real my buddy would we would go
to this there was this one Street in our
um block that or in our neighborhood
that was like obnoxiously wide for some
reason it was way wider than all of the
other streets and it was like a kind of
an in-between Street and we would just
do donuts in that and my buddies and I
uh but mainly my buddies because it was
my car would go on the roof of the car
no and no straps not just hold on to the
room play or like squat hold or you
score Spider-Man or are you like no
they're like they're like laying they're
laying down
um but we're doing donuts and they're
just holding on to it and like one of us
you know we probably like regret his
ankle from inside the car or something
but like just almost in an effort to
like let's see if we can throw him from
the top of this car onto the concrete
um and shockingly nobody like it was one
of those things was like the only time
someone fell was like right as we were
stopping and they kind of just rolled
off but I mean easily could have been
killed any of us dead dead dead I don't
know how anybody makes it past 16. we
were Reckless we used to have this uh
Bridge it was on the 32 route 32 and um
it was a hundred feet from the top so
there were Rafters under it there were
about 50 yeah and then the top was a
hundred we took a tape measure measured
it and when you're swimming under it and
you look up it doesn't look that way
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's up there
but when you get up there and you look
over and the first thing you will see
are like leaves or something floating on
the water tops it gives you a
perspective right holy [__]
so people started to want to jump off of
it and it became this like after school
thing people go down to watch people do
it other people would swear they're
going to do it and
um we had known of an arrival school
it's called South Carroll for us we were
Liberty there South Carolina one of the
kids there I think they were doing night
swimming and he jumped and apparently
there's a cable or something way down
there and I guess his foot got stuck and
he never came up so we would only do it
during the day yeah he died oh [__] we
would only do this during the day and we
would only do it if we would have six or
seven people swimming out in the water
so if you came down they would dive down
right away right to be there at least to
try to help you there were people that
would wait up in the rafters and jump in
if you needed more help
um because that wasn't that high 50
Feet's not that bad you know it's bad
yeah it's tough but 100 is stupid 100 is
uh insane and so we had this one we're
still friends this day as one kid Chris
Sheila was always like uh you know I'm
gonna do it
every day he's gonna do and he never
does it so one day
I go you know what if you do it I'll do
it he's like are you serious I go yes
because you're not going to [__] do
it right so we walk up we get on and a
guy comes up with us to make sure that
if he goes I go and I said you don't
need to make sure if he goes I'm going
but he's not going right and we're up
there for 20 [__] minutes and cars
they're riding by you know and um I'm
like you're not doing it so I turn
around and I just hear this noise I just
hear and I turn back around he is
[__] gone and I look over and this
motherfucker's screaming going my God a
hundred feet dude he did it
and he went in he came up screaming like
yeah yeah I'm like no pain I didn't get
hurt no well some people certainly did
so um I'll tell you what happened so I
had to do it and it took me a while I
got out over the edge and I held back
and I kept letting go you know waiting
for the Miss and I wasn't missing yeah I
was not missing and then I Let Go
and I pin dropped in and man the water
maybe the first eight feet is warm it's
Sunbeam yeah yeah man you go down deep
it's Pitch Black it's [__] cold down
there so I panic you know I panic swim
back up and I'm all stoked that I did it
and I get out and the next day in school
my ass yeah and the bottoms of my
[__] feet uh-huh from slapping that
hard [__] hurt so bad I couldn't sit
in my chair comfortably or whatever a
girl went up and did it didn't close her
legs she got her vagina torn yeah
to go to the ER because she got a tear
porn torn bro it's 100 feet up yeah you
can't be going down recklessly
yeah she's just riding a bullet
dude get out of my brother he's an idiot
so he decided that jumping it wasn't
enough anymore now somebody's got a
jackass yeah you know
and they were trying to flip off and my
brother made the mistake of uh he got
scared but instead of flipping straight
out he sort of went off to that that
flip where you go this way you know that
that I'm not fully committed yeah yeah
yeah the panic and he won wildly coming
down he slapped on his ribs he came up
we have it on video somebody still has
that song oh my God and he was spitting
up blood for like a day did he go to the
hospital no sick that's what I'm saying
he's that idiot he's like just classic
there's a glass more in a day I'll do it
and he didn't dude I the only thing I've
I jumped off a 62 foot cliff in Hawaii
once and I was watching I like it's like
a just a jutted out into the ocean kind
of a thing and it was like a long it
would be like a long swim back it was
like a few and it was like a pretty
strong it was in Kauai he's like a very
strong current just to be a really
strong swimmer and I was that's the
that's the thing we didn't have this was
just Lake dead water you know this was
like like strong current so I'm like
pretty nervous about it I'm like worried
about is it even deep enough are there
rocks here and I saw like local like
Hawaiian dudes like literally like not
even break stride from climbing up this
thing and then just do three front flips
and land and then just swim and go and
oh yeah dude I was up there for probably
30 to 35 minutes by myself just being
like
and people are like hiking past me being
like are you jumping
they've circled around you still here
literally someone did someone went I
can't believe he's still here
it was this old couple that finally gave
me the courage because I was like an old
guy what I was the other thing too
because I'm like one of the times I was
I'm not making this episode one of the
times I was about to jump I had like the
the like the my legs were bent I looked
down and where I was planning on jumping
was a [__] sea turtle like at the top
and I'm like if I landed on a just
shattered everything you know so I I
told this old couple who had a dinosaur
what fly just hit me yeah it just melted
and so I tell those the older couple
that saw me go by and I was like just
can you like if I just you know make
sure that I come up you know and if not
go tell somebody because my wife was
like at the pool you know and she was
like nowhere no one was there right so I
I finally jumped off and dude I did like
the the running kind of like running
bicycle thing and the other thing dude
I'm sure you experienced too you just
never you're falling for salt law I
can't even imagine 162 feet you're I was
falling and then you're like gaining
speed as it's going and you're well
aware
why haven't I hit the water yet you know
and then when I hit I was like I think I
was like in between running because I do
I landed on like my ass and thigh and
like you said dude Ike for the rest of
that trip I had my whole back of my leg
was completely bruised it's not like a
slap I couldn't sit down it was none of
that so I I had totally uh relate to
what you're saying but I can't imagine
that a hundred feet and then I found out
that same Cliff I found this out
afterwards that same Cliff Justin Bieber
had jumped off of and it it blew out his
eardrum geez so he had to like cancel
his entire tour it was like a notorious
like don't do this clip oh no [__] yeah
so I ended up I again had I known that I
probably wouldn't know I've told this
story before in a a long time ago
probably on the crab feast and people
call [__] but I I called my younger
brother after I told him I go people
don't believe that [__] story so
off to the side of that bridge you got
the bridge about 100 and then there's a
cliff off to the side yeah to the left
and what we used to do is take we take
our swimming masks and stuff and we'd
all swim the bottom make sure there were
no rocks under there because it's
obviously not clear water or anything
and everybody'd be like this is a good
spot to go and then there was just a
place we called the Rock and it was just
a little you know 10 foot jump off and
just hang out people are drinking
smoking whatever but this was just off
so some people were jumping off the
bridge here and then you just come down
here for the people that were not as
stupid right yeah and wanted to do
something a little less dumb and we
always would play [__] dumb like oh
you know Jaws something's pulling you
under somebody go out and we'd always
yell snake snake or whatever and one
time my [__] brother jumps in
and he's out there swimming and we look
out and there's a [__] water moccasin
that's hauling ass right coming right at
him yeah in the water a snake and we're
screaming snake snake but we've yelled
snake so many [__] cried wolf exactly
he doesn't even he said whatever we're
like we're all now we're all doing it
we're throwing rocks he's like stop he
turns around this motherfucker's like
yeah he's like oh my God yeah he starts
swimming I'm like I don't think he's
gonna [__] make it my friend this
true story Jeff Wagner he was like this
is like late neighborhood Legend [__] he
was the guy the you know best player in
baseball he went to University of
Maryland he was really [__] good
this kid takes one of those flat like
Shale rocks and he [__] throws it and
I promise you Mike [__] Feeney it cut
that goddamn snake no way to say like if
you had said he just hit it I'd be like
that cut it in half
and it broke like this and then it
slowly floated like this so we were like
yeah
we're going nuts we're going nuts I call
my brother after I told that story
because people like you're full of [__]
I'm like Todd they don't [__] believe
he's like Wagner through that rock and
cut the snake at him in half it cut in
half he goes they cut it again I was
like oh my God you actually weirdly just
reminded me of a near-death experience
that I had that I've forgotten about to
tell you about that I might have blacked
out on purpose
um I was so I was this was in between
one of my years of college it's probably
after my freshman year of college when
my mom my mom moved to Florida at that
point so she's uh you know I I would
work at a surf shop during the day right
on the beach and I would go surfing like
all the time right so one of the first
times I went there the first time it was
like New Smyrna Beach which is kind of
like a great surfing Beach on the east
coast of Florida also the shark bite
capital of the world it is sure yeah and
not they have like the East Coast yeah
it's like six foot not deaths like bites
all these six foot yeah whatever sharks
that come in so they get people get bit
then they go to like get stitched up and
go right back out surfing it's like so
that's like the notion I'm having going
into this so I'm I'm starting to paddle
out I'm kind of near the Jetties you
know where like the surf point is I'm
starting to paddle out and then suddenly
I see as I'm paddling I'm getting closer
like the current taking me closer to the
jetty so I was like oh that's not good
so I turned my board to paddle away from
the Jetties and the current I mean
within it felt like seconds took me out
past the past the Jetties and on the
other side of it which was oh you went
around just open ocean there's like no
beach there's no nothing it's just I'm
gone and like I want to say not to
interrupt you but there's a place in
Ocean City Maryland they call it the
inlet it's where the Bayside meets the
ocean where they literally touch at the
end of that right and it's
it's okay over here and if you go over
there you're by yourself yeah so I'm
like and like the beach is packed and
seemingly nobody is seeing me drift away
and I'm starting to do that thing of
like ah I was a lifeguard something like
I'm a great swimmer so I'm kind of
swimming I'm panicking a little bit but
I'm like it's okay and everyone's just
getting further and further away I'm
kind of like waving to people no one's
doing anything I get onto that other
side of the Jetties now I'm just an open
ocean no one can even see me anymore so
I'm freaking out so I go I'm losing
ground on this uh on this board so I'm
gonna jump off and I'll swim so I jump
off and I start trying to swim and I'm
like really swimming hard and I'm not
gaining or losing ground like I'm just
in place essentially and I'm getting
starting to get tired and now I'm like
really starting to freak out and how
long you think you're out there at this
point I must have been out there like
like alone probably like at least like
15 minutes yeah well like of just being
like alone alone are you trying to
signal for anything only people that I
could still see where there were like
some older Asian fishermen that were on
like the Jetties of the Rocks they're
not even facing my direction though
they're just kind of like you know real
and stuff and so I'm like panicking dude
and again keeping in mind shark bite
Capital all alone looking like a seal
you know what I mean like just not good
so then I realized uh I remembered from
being a lifeguard like that you know be
doing like the backstroke is a lot less
effort than doing the front stroke so I
started doing the backstroke and I'm
actually like gaining a little bit of
ground but I'm still like working my ass
off so I I dude I backstroke for at
least another five to ten minutes and I
finally got towards the other side of
the Jetties and one of those Asian
fishermen like saw me and like scaled
down the thing into that and like
brought me back up as I'm getting like
I'm getting like crashed into the Rocks
dude my board is all like in pieces Ding
and it's all Sharp Rock so I'm like I'm
bleeding which again now the blood with
the sharks yeah I'm getting like every
day he's like trying to reach me and
then the current would smash me into the
rocks and I'm my my elbows cut
everything's cut like I'm just getting
uh annihilated by these waves and this
one and and then my of course the board
leash is stuck to the thing and my board
was all broken anyway and the guy was
like yelling at me he's like just leave
the [__] more words I was like all
right so I like left the board out and
then I you know he got me back up I'm
all bloody and stuff and I go over to my
family and like friends that are at the
beach with me and I'm like hey
what the [__]
guys like they're all like what's up and
I'm like look at me where's my board
like you didn't see me I was out there
and they're like we thought that was you
and to be fair like it was every white
guy like look at the surfboard like we
thought that guy was yeah that guy and
then my friends are just like drinking a
beer on the beach as I'm just about to
die I mean it's just it was uh it was
terrifying dude it would be in that
ocean like that side of it I had that
like
okay okay yeah it was it was so long and
um yeah man it was it was a very
terrifying experience dude I've had a
couple of those in my life where it's
like you can't communicate when you're
going through that panic and you just
need somebody to pay attention like this
is completely unrelated to that but it
is a similar thing where I didn't like
learn how to ride a bike until I was way
too old you know like I was way too old
I asked my I I asked my dad before I
came to do this I was like what's the
internet we ballparked it somewhere
between 10 or 12 but closer to like 12.
yeah but it's too old
because it's embarrassingly old because
the first time I went to ride a bike my
dad put steering wheel uh training
wheels on and as I was riding around the
block with my neighborhood the training
wheel flew off and I went into the
street almost got hit by a car so it
freaked me out so I wouldn't go for
years so what I was doing was I was on
like the big wheelie remember that it's
like the tricycle with like plastic
tires and all that stuff and I would try
to like keep up with my friends were
riding bikes at this point I'm on like
on a scooter you know I'm like trying to
like keep up with them and stuff at my
next door neighbor Stephanie she was
awesome she was like five years older
than me or maybe a little bit less but
she was older than me and she was deaf
and um and she would she'd be on a
mountain bike I was still on this big
wheelie these plastic tricycle things
yeah the power break back yeah yeah
yeah so uh so I came up with this great
idea because I can never keep up with
her because she was on a mountain bike
because I was like here's what we'll do
let's tie my big wheelie to your
mountain bike and then you just kind of
take off and I'll like be going as fast
it'll be sick you know and so we tie it
up and then um I sit down in the big
wheelie and before I can grab this
because we tied it to the middle of the
steering column the second before I
could grab the steering column she just
takes off and it turned the steering
column sideways into my chest like
locking me in place and we know about
that chest and we know about that as it
was right in the hole
Yeah
but the the tire was turned sideways
right so it could only position so it
was like that and she was like like
grinding it and so it just flipped me
over with only my elbows and knees being
dragged oh the concrete on the sidewalk
so now I'm like just I'm losing and this
is the point where you as a kid you're
like that was a [__] dumb idea but
not a problem we'll just yell out to
Stephanie God damn it she's deaf she
can't hear anything
she peddled for like a full two houses
or turning around standing up yeah she's
like you know and she is at I'm just
like Dread elbows and knees I don't know
if you can see like I have scars on my
elbows
I'm dragged on my elbows and knees by a
deaf girl and she turned around like
being like uh-huh
blood blood
[Music]
bloodline Street and a child screaming
for his life dude
hahaha
oh I heard SpongeBob yeah well it hurt
my elbows and knees Mike Venus has been
a fun really fun [__] episode thanks
for having me yeah dude thank you for
coming in and uh I told you before we
recording your first time here so after
everything we've talked about tell me
advice you would give to 16 year old
Mike Feeney uh man I mean at this point
you know the the bad part is like with
the with the business part of Comedy I'd
be like start a YouTube page immediately
and get you know and get because I was
always shooting like you know dumb
little sketches jackass type things I
was like man if I was putting those
online when I was 16 I mean sure I would
have it would have been pretty bad at
this point but at least like that thing
but in terms of just like personal
advice it's like that kind of like the
don't freak out about the future like
things are gonna work out like don't
stress about you know that kind of that
dumb like everything happens for a
reason or wherever you're you're always
at where you're supposed to be at kind
of a thing
um because there's so many times I've
like you know I do that what was the
thing you said outside of future what
was tripping future tripping I do that a
lot so there's always that like well if
I do this like especially before we had
the kid we're like yeah but then if I do
this then it's like I'm already so busy
with stand-ups and then how am I going
to add this kid and then attack and then
what does that mean now we can't fit in
this apartment so now we got to move to
another you know I just you go down that
whole thing and you're like you figure
it out you know what I mean like you
just can't you can't plan for all the
variables that are gonna come so it's
just like you'll [__] figure it out
man it'll be fine or it won't but
freaking out about it now is not gonna
is not gonna change anything that's
great advice dude yeah um please plug
and promote everything again Mike
feeneycomedy.com uh for tour dates and
all that uh link to my first uh comedy
special Rage Against the routine which
is on my YouTube channel youtube.com
mikefini comedy at I am Mike Feeney
across all social media come see me in
Chicago at the Den theater on October
7th and Algonquin theater uh September
15th check out my podcast here's a
scenario uh my Canon and Brennan sagalo
it's a fun time and uh yeah thanks for
having me oh yeah man I appreciate it
was a lot of fun this is fun um as
always Ryan sickler.com Ryan sickler on
all your social media go to YouTube
watch the special and get your tickets
come out and see me on the road we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
foreign